aujourd'hui gunet élève de 3e année est
plutôt fier il fait le guide pour ses
camarades de deuxième année de l'école
supérieure de fonderie et de forges de
Sèvres nous avons le bras auto robotisé
qui vient chercher avec son bassin de
couler le métal et ensuite il va aller
vers la coquille pour remplir le métal
dans le moule permanent ce futur
ingénieur a choisi le métier par passion
il y a aussi la maîtrise le savoir-faire
autour de ce métier c'est ce qui m'a
intéressé les culasses de moteur
représentent 70% de l'activité près de
600000 pièces par an mais c'est bientôt
du passé et l'entreprise a déjà commencé
à prendre le virage du véhicule
électrique depuis à peu près une bonne
année maintenant on a obtenu 6 nouveaux
marchés pour domaine électrique donc
nouveau segment et nouveaux clients le
site emploi 215 salariés l'an prochain
l'effectif devrait passer à 260 est
fabriqué 800000 pièces à ce poste on
assemble le noyau l'intérieur du moteur
autour duquel va couler l'aluminium
aux à la pas à l'heure mais on a gardé
l'opérateur
donc on a pas supprimé l'opérateur
l'opérateur fait plus de noyau en étant
dans le meilleur condition chaque année
en France près de 40 000 ingénieurs
sortent des écoles il en faudrait 20000
de plus pour répondre à la demande et la
fonderie n'échappe pas à la pénurie nous
on diplôme 30 ingénieurs par an donc il
faudrait qu'on soit entre 50 à 60 et ça
veut dire qu'un autre échelle c'est
quand même doubler notre effectif
heureusement les femmes sont de plus en
plus nombreuses à l'école près d'un
tiers de la promo de berline
déjà et du coup les entreprises la
plupart du temps viennent nous chercher
à l'école directement en nous proposant
voilà nos composants des choses quand
même assez intéressantes et les salaires
moyens proposés en sortie d'école sont
autour de 40000 euros soit 3300 euros
brut par mois chaussures de sécurité
casque et bouchon d'oreille sont fournis
par les fonderies